so the newest version of iOS was
revealed by Apple about a month ago
which means sometime in the next few
months your iPhone's going to change
for the better luckily as long as you
have an iPhone 8 or later
this is iOS 16.
[Music]
so I've had the beta for iOS 16 on this
iPhone for about a month played around
with it a lot it's not stable enough to
make your main just yet just warning you
but there's a lot of good stuff here
some of which Apple did talk about on
stage some of which they didn't either
way this is the five best features in
iOS 16. so number five the ability to
edit and unsend messages so I realize
I've only been asking to do this on
Twitter but apparently people have
wanted this for iMessage too so now you
can long press the message you send and
for up to 15 minutes after you first
send something you can edit and then
type what you actually meant to send and
it'll revise to whoever you sent it to
or if you're just so disgusted with what
you originally sent you can actually
unsend a message completely which is
pretty sweet if you do either of these
things the other person will see that it
was edited but won't see the edit
history and if you undo send it just
leaves an alert in place for both people
by the way just as a heads up if you go
to try this feature with someone who
isn't on on iOS 16 yet it won't work so
they won't see the edit on their end or
the undo on their end so they'll still
see the crazy terrible message you
initially sent uh you've been warned but
that brings us to number four which is
live objects now I think I gotta just
sort of rewind just a little bit so you
can understand or at least fully
appreciate how amazing this is so you
remember live text right live text lets
you open any picture with text in it and
it immediately recognizes that text and
lets you interact with it lets you copy
paste it somewhere Etc iOS 16 also adds
live text in videos so if you pause a
video on a frame with text somewhere in
it you can lift that text from inside
the video that way but the cherry on top
is now in a photo with a subject and a
background you can long press and
literally lift any object out of a photo
to copy and paste into whatever you want
messages for example so it erases the
background does all the masking for you
and does a surprise amazingly good job
for a literal one second background
delete you can do this with seemingly
any photo too it's not just like
portrait mode photos shot on the iPhone
it can be shot on any camera as a matter
of fact any picture it just seems to
need to have a reasonable subject versus
background and the iPhone will just
figure it out I am very impressed I'll
be making all kinds of stickers for our
Discord now so then number three for me
is
the little things just all the little
things added up together this is one of
those things where like iOS still looks
and feels like iOS it's not that
dramatic of an overhaul but when you add
together all these small things it does
feel like a pretty nice refresh and I I
like pretty much all the things I
changed I like that the weather app
finally shows you individual daytime
forecasts now it's crazy that it took
them buying dark sky to finally
Implement all this but now for one day
you can see how the temperature will
move and fluctuate throughout the day or
when it will rain Etc love it I like the
new video watching UI if you choose to
watch a video in Safari now clean simple
I like that face ID Works in landscape
now it's a small touch but finally thank
you I like that the home screen says
search at the bottom where you can pull
up a slightly refreshed Spotlight search
UI pops up from the bottom now and I use
Spotlight all the time so I notice this
right away and I like that the things
you order with the Apple card will start
showing up in the wallet app it's self
so if you keep track of everything there
then rip to some package tracking apps
and I know a lot of people that will
like the iPhone finally has a haptic
keyboard
is one of those things that Android has
had for
so many years a decade at this point
probably since the beginning but it's
funny because it's one of those things
that immediately lets me feel when a
phone has a good haptic engine or not
because first thing you do is type in a
Wi-Fi password and you can feel the
haptic keyboard and it's either a soft
mushy haptics or really tight and clicky
the good ones I leave it on the bad ones
I'll turn it off so the iPhone literally
has the best vibration motor on any
phone so it's about damn time the
keyboard gets the haptic feedback and
it's very good it's off by default but
you can easily hop into settings and
turn it on so there's always a bunch of
little things with software updates that
sort of add up to a bigger change and I
kind of like all these they're really
good but now it's time for the bigger
things so number two is continuity
camera this one
might be my personal favorite but it's
the one I got the biggest announcement
reaction on stage and it was the biggest
shocker so it's super cool so basically
over the years our smartphone cameras
have gotten better and better but
webcams in laptops not so much I mean it
was only the M1 MacBooks in 2020 where
Apple finally updated to a 1080p webcam
but it still looks worse than a normal
phone camera so Apple had this brilliant
idea why don't we use the good cameras
that we make which are the iPhone
cameras as your webcam
genius so you've got to have IOS 16 and
the latest version of Mac OS Ventura to
do it but once you've got all that going
continuity camera wirelessly turns your
iPhone into your Macs webcam so doing
that not only looks infinitely better
but also gives you access to all the
other cool things that your iPhone's
camera can do like portrait mode Studio
light and Center Stage if you want it's
pretty sick but easily the coolest part
of this is called desk view so by using
your phone's Ultra wide camera when it's
mounted on top of your laptop or your
monitor you can get your standard webcam
View and this top down view of
whatever's on your desk in front of you
so in this case it's basically showing
what's right in front of your keyboard
where your hands are at anything that's
pretty flat to the ground it seems like
black magic but it works pretty well
that's a lot of software processing
going on to take the edge of the ultra
wide frame and flip it upside down and
turn it into this perfect top-down view
but I can see this being crazy useful in
so many circumstances as long as
whatever object you're working with is
pretty flat so that is dope and that
brings us to number one which is the new
lock screen this is the biggest visual
most obvious change to iOS it's got the
most new stuff here and it's just all
the customization of the clock and the
wallpaper and all the stuff going on so
let's just jump right in so first things
first the lock screen looks different
right away new clock font matching
colors some widgets so to start
customizing your lock screen you just
hold it down and then hit the customize
button and then just tap what you want
to start to customize so you can mess
with the font and the color of course to
get the contrast right so things are
readable and then up above the clock and
below the clock you have slots to add
widgets you can see I already have a few
here and it's kind of like adding them
to your home screen you just pick the
one you want to add tap it or click to
drag it in and the widgets below the
clock are very much just like watch
complications they're these little
square glanceable pieces of information
that you can't really interact much with
but when you click them they open the
app that they're associated with and the
ones above the clock are mainly just a
text format so they make a lot of sense
for maybe calendar events or weather
things like that so you can already play
around endlessly with just that
combination of things you can mess with
the clock the weather the widgets
whatever else you want to put in there
but then what's nice is you can save
your layout what you've made and then go
to create a new one so now you can save
multiple different lock screens that
you've customized and set up and just
like watch faces on the Apple watch you
can just hold it down and switch between
any of these ones you've made at any
time but now here's an extra wrench to
throw into this whole equation if you
don't add any bottom widgets so if you
just have your clock and maybe a top
widget there's a new feature where the
clock will Nestle itself between the
foreground and the background of your
wallpaper and this was not just for like
portrait mode photos or photos from the
iPhone this is any photo so Apple's
using a little bit more of their AI
their impressive object recognition from
that live objects feature earlier and
it's able to with pretty impressive
consistency give me some pretty cool
cutouts it's really too bad it doesn't
work once you add widgets under the time
at least in this beta so you have to
choose between a cool clock cut out and
lots of widgets on your home screen but
I think this feature is pretty sweet
when it works and I am also a fan of
this little animation you're seeing
where when you unlock it fades in the
foreground just before it fades in the
background from black it's a nice touch
now to take this even further you can
associate any lock screen that you make
with a focus mode so if you have a focus
mode like for work for example you could
already do a certain home screen for
work now you can have a certain lock
screen for work then you can have a home
and lock screen for going to sleep going
to the gym going home whatever all that
stuff just ties and switches
automatically and then also now that
your lock screen is so much prettier the
notifications roll in and they don't
cover your Masterpiece anymore they roll
in from the bottom so I really like that
change it's good for reachability on
phones of all screen sizes but also just
seems to make chronological sense the
way they've been rolling in and they
keep rolling in from the bottom without
interrupting your precious lock screen
you can choose to display notifications
as a stack a list or account in the past
they'd always been a list that's what
we're used to but I like them as a stack
now it's more Compact and another cool
feature Apple added is called live
activities this is basically an app that
will update its notification live with
new information instead of sending you
new notifications over and over again so
something like when your Uber is getting
closer and closer to you before it picks
you up or maybe live sports scores just
update to scoreboard I really like the
new music live activity it's much
smaller than the huge widget was before
and you can still script through songs
it's great and also the new live timer
notifications pretty sweet just having
that little animation to count down the
seconds just a good amount of Polish
here on the lock screen and I think
that's really the highlight of iOS 16 is
just people we're going to be out here
customizing their lock screens doing
crazy stuff with the way they that's the
thing that you interact with the most on
your phone how many times do you think
maybe a hundred times a day you unlock
your phone and look at the wallpaper and
your lock screen it's a big deal so
that's pretty much it for iOS 16 let me
know what your favorite feature is in
the comments below and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace
thank you